[Music]
when I first started climbing I was so
bad
I was so terrible so slow and tear my
skin up all the time I was like how the
heck are we going to go and do Mount
Kilimanjaro three words I don't know
there's three words three and the most
important words in my life all
discoveries happen from I don't know
my name is Kyle Maynard and I have an
extremely hard time saying what it is
exactly that I do
I've been an athlete my entire life
football to wrestling to weightlifting
and resigning jujitsu and now most
recently taking on I'm in some of the
highest mountains in the world I was
born with congenital amputation the
basically means my arms and at the
elbows my legs and at the knees you know
I think some people they look at me and
maybe even feel sorry for me but really
truthfully my life doesn't look a whole
lot different than yours you know I I
find my computer the same way you know I
use my phone just like anybody else
I'm on bumble like anybody any other
single person my age we got a match my
first experience with climbing really
anything of significance was in a
CrossFit competition in 2010 the first
workout was you had to do a
thousand-meter row in the throwing
machine in a sprint up Stone Mountain
everybody else did it maybe 25 minutes
it took me an hour and 46 minutes at
oralists getting up on my arm but I got
to the top and I was like wow this is
breathtakingly beautiful and I told my
friend that night I said I want to climb
Mount Kilimanjaro I don't know if I can
I don't know if I can't but I do know
that I want to try to figure it out I
want to go and find a way and and get up
there
[Music]
there were a ton of challenges with
getting into climbing and the biggest
one was the gear I literally started
with back out duct-taped my hands to my
feet I couldn't go to the store and buy
a typical pair of shoes so we had to
come up with a unique solution now to
climb I use a carbon fiber special
custom shoe I use those to bear crawl up
Kilimanjaro then my team we took on
climbing Mount Aconcagua the highest
peak in South America I felt my body was
looking full shot down mode
and it was brutal at moments but it was
breathtakingly beautiful at the top of
that mountain you know you can almost
kind of make out and see like the
curvature of the earth I mean it was
just a moment I'll never forget the
reasons I climb aren't that different
from other people 95% of it does suck
I'm staring as a dirt I'm not even able
to go and talk to my friends and see the
beautiful views in life they stop and
sit down and look but that 5% that
doesn't suck
it's amazing get into a place that
there's no way my wheelchair could have
brought me there that's what I love I'm
not trying to live to be a thousand like
I want to I want to go out there and
have my life meaning something when it's
gotten down and I've looked at the
mountain and I see what we've achieved
it's like wow maybe that was a really
bad idea that we were there but it was
beautiful